ben how did you know you were ready to
make a feature film
i
i didn't think about that you know what
i i
maybe i was not ready i just actually i
just went out and made the film and that
i think came from an impulse of just i
wanted to make my feature film so
i didn't think about anything
and we just
went and made the movie and that's
after the film the shooting itself that
we realized hmm
i we just did that in
a crazy
uh
amount of time i mean we were so fast
and we just and at the end it was like
it was like a train going um
and just going so fast and we were just
jumping on a train and just and when the
train
stopped we were like wow we've been
doing all this work together and we
didn't
uh realized about that i mean it because
it was so fast and so
and i think that's a great thing because
sometimes
when you are thinking too much about
making a movie you can
you can kill it by overthinking and
taking too much time in the at the end
not making the movie whereas
us
with my
co-producer todd bartu
and our actors we just went and made the
movie
what was that first thing that you did
because i know you were taking the
um filmmaking class at ucla extension
right
and you were supposed to make a short
but you said you know what i think i
want to make a feature right exactly so
the thesis film at ucla was about was
supposed to be 15 minutes long
and i
over the course of two months i just
wrote
and rewrote and rewrote and rewrote this
ping on script and i knew i wanted to
make that and so i went and see them and
i asked them okay so can i can i use the
first act
the first 15 minute act as my thesis
film
and let me do the rest the feature of
him for myself and they were like okay
and so
after that we just went out and made the
movie and made the movie
uh
which was
um which was 70 pages long so and but i
knew a lot of it was going to be
based on improv because i love to work
with improv with my character so
at the end at the end of the day we have
a 1 hour and 32 minutes long movie which
is the perfect fit for the movie